well I representing my confidence I am
the greatest I cannot lose I'm pretty
and every man believes he's the greatest
every man would like to be the greatest
men and want to say this but they feared
and they see this in myself with some
hate me before and some love missile
[Music]
do you have a bodyguard no you don't I
got one bodyguard he has no eyes though
he sees he has no ears though he hears
he remembers everything with the aid of
my amendment when he wishes to create a
thing he just orders it to be and it
comes into existence that's God
he's my buddy guy he's your bodyguard
he's the Supreme
what would you like people to think
about you when you've gone I'd like for
them to say he took a few cups of love
he took one tablespoon of patience
one teaspoon of generosity one pint of
kindness he took one quart of laughter
one pinch of concern and then he mixed
willingness what happened is he added
lots of faith and he stirred it up well
then he spreaded over a span of a
lifetime and he served it to each and
every deserving person he met I studied
life I studied people and I'm educated
on this but when it comes to reading and
writing I'm not I may be illiterate in
that but when it comes to Common Sense
when it comes to feelings when it comes
to love compassion her heart for people
then I I'm rich I wrote something once
it says where is man's wealth his wealth
is in his knowledge for his wealth was
in the bank and not in his knowledge
then he don't possess it because it's in
the bank you know my wealth is in my
knowledge if I'm a spokesman for my
people and I want to represent my people
and I don't want to be a bad
representative I can't be blind because
the blind leader blind they all fall in
the ditch
no I want to say something right here
you all might this might make you all
think
life is not really long let's say the
average person 30 years old
if you're 30 years old you would not
been about seven years old how can I
prove it add up all the seven eight nine
hours you slept for 30 years
out of 30 years out of all the nights
last night when you went to bed and woke
up this morning you don't remember a
thing
you've been unconscious for about eight
years if you're 30 years old you slept
about eight years okay
how much traveling have you done in 30
years and the television station to home
to another country it's another city to
school to church you've probably
traveled two years your life has been
just getting back and forth to where
you're going so there's eight years of
sleeping two years of traveling there's
30 years out of your life before you
accomplish anything how long do you sit
in school in America we stay in school
from the first grade to 12th grade six
hours a day for 12 years break it down
you set in a classroom for three years
without leaving okay two years of
traveling eight years of sleeping three
years of school how many movies have you
went to how many wrestling matches how
much entertainment how many movie
theaters live plays baseball games
probably two years of entertainment so
by the time a man you older people know
him bear with us I'm saying by the time
you have children by the time you have
uh made a way for your children by the
time you've paid for your home you
pushing 60 years old
so life is real short
see I lead that's the only thing about
our league when you were watching Ali
get beaten up as an old man even that
was a young kid he's not gonna quit you
got to kill him he won't quit even he's
gonna be up every round getting kicked
out of my life at home it's a champ no
come on let me out come on out they
wouldn't stop he had to be he would have
to stay up in his take the beating like
a man he wouldn't quit and the way I
respect the guy like that so much I have
so much admiration for a guy like that
so much but it's just not right to be
that way as a human being this is over I
come back and fight another day else you
got me you know and listen um I always
like to think I'm a bad if I don't give
a f but I'm that's a part of our lead
that's where he overshines me because I
can't understand the man that's willing
to just really die for this you know and
I talked
but he did why does it make you
emotional is he told by him or a
relation to you
me me
um I leave the giant there's no other
buddies can match you he'll die for this
[ __ ] die I'm not gonna die for that
everybody has a purpose in life
everybody has a Destiny and the
knowledge of that Destiny enables one to
fulfill it see so everything was put
here for purpose ants buzzards trees and
it's the knowing of that purpose that
enables every man to fulfill it
and uh
and life begins when a person realizes
his purpose in life with very few people
uh know how to go about finding what's
the best purpose
in their life that they should try to
fulfill and mine was just to be the
World Heavyweight Champion
and then also not only been the champion
but keeping my dignity my pride and my
manhood not Uncle Thomas as they say
selling out my people just for the white
man's dollar so this is my purpose to go
down as the one the first one just about
to go all out and all the way and being
clean with the sport and and not
represent nothing like tobacco and
whiskey and various commercials and
stand with my people
and representing everybody at the same
time not just owning my own marrying my
own kind and socializing with my own
kind
but I belong to the world as far as
being the champion but I'll let it be
known that I am black and I will always
be black and with black even if I mean
give up all the money and everything
that I can be offered from boxing
my head got big and I started thinking
it was my training camp and my boxing
ability that kept me where I was at and
God punished me and he gave me a good
whooping he broke my joy in a second
fight and he got me whooped and knocked
down in the freezer fight and I realized
I wasn't that great after all so I had
to get not only together physically but
spiritually for this fight I prayed
every day for five days five times a day
for the past uh uh four months and
everything is perfect
and if Allah is with me it ain't no way
no man can win no way cause I'm
representing God I'm representing the
freedom of black people in America I
want to be the one black man who stands
up and look at white people and tell the
truth who don't sell them out who don't
uncle Dom who don't promote cigarettes
don't promote risky take his Fame to
uplift his little brother in the ghetto
how do we treat each other how do we
help each other so
I'm gonna dedicate my life to using my
name in popularity helping Charities
helping people uniting people bringing
people bombing each other because of
religious beliefs we need somebody in
the world to help us or make peace so
when I die if there's a heaven I want to
see it because we live hello 80 years
the odds are everybody in this room some
of you gonna be dead 20 years from now
some of you gonna be dead 50 years from
now some are going to be dead 30 and
someone will be there six to 70 years
ago we all gonna die soon and if you
live to be say a 125 years old which we
don't do right let's say we live to be
250 and you can have sex for 145 of
those years you're going to come to end
after that
so we don't have it about 80 years on
Earth
this is a test to see where will we
spend our life in heaven hell this is
not the life now your real self is
inside you your body gets old some of
you go to look at the fridge you'll go
you don't have no teeth your hair is
leaving you your bodies get tired but
your soul and your spirit never die
that's gonna live forever so your body
is just housing your soul and spirit so
God is testing us on how we treat each
other how we live to see where our real
home be in heaven so this physical stuff
don't last for so long so my car this
building is going to be here when the
man who built a dead there have been
many kings and queens of England they're
all dead after this one is gone another
one will come so we don't stay here
we're just trustees we don't own nothing
so what am I saying
the most important thing about life is
what's going to happen when you die